Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Seth Moskowitz, who's a journalist writing
about American politics and technology and
an editor at Persuasion Magazine.
He's also author of the article The Reactionary
Trap, which I've talked about before with
my audience.
Seth, really great having you on today.
Speaker 3: Thank you very much for having
me.
I'm excited to be here.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, just just to start
with, let's talk about I have made the case
to my audience that much of what is currently
associated with the American right wing is
not really conservative by any definition
of the term, but is really a sort of neo reactionary
movement.
Can you talk a little bit about when we say
reactionary?
What what are the characteristics of a reactionary
political movement or policy or positions?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Well, fundamentally, what a reactionary is.
Somebody who wants to go back to the way things
were before, politically or socially.
Essentially, they want to roll back the clock.
So we're a progressive might want to see some
form of change to push things into the future.
Conservative might be a little bit more focused
on tradition and skeptical of change, but
maybe more open to it a reactionary somebody
who wants to roll back the clock to the way
things were before.
And so in my article, I lay out two things
that I think kind of are hallmarks of a reactionary.
The first is that they lose sight of any sense
of proportionality, something that they see
as a threat.
They are not able to kind of judge if it's
a five alarm fire or if it's something that's
kind of a minor threat that they should be
minor league concerns about.
And the second is that their politics becomes
one of opposition.
They lose sight of their their principles
and their values and the things that they
want to see in the world, and they become
focused only on opposing things that they
dislike.
Speaker 1: Now, in hearing that it really
sounds like Trumpism, right?
I mean, like when I hear you say that, I think,
OK, so a movement of opposition.
Here's something Joe Biden wants to do.
Nope, we're not going to.
We don't want him to do that.
Here's something Barack Obama did.
Now here's why we're going to undo it without
really bringing policy proposals to the table.
And also the fear piece, which is critical.
Race theory is going to be a disaster with
no proportionality in terms of is it actually
something that's being taught trans bathroom
issues or trans women in sports with no sense
of the scope of these issues?
Am I right in applying it in this way?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think so.
And I think the important thing that I've
noticed is that really what it feels like
to me is our dividing line in politics seems
to be this culture war.
And I think what happens with reactionaries
is they kind of glom onto the politics of
the day and the thing that's making people
most furious and most angry.
And today, that's the culture, war and social
issues.
So when I think about who is a reactionary
in contemporary politics, I don't think about
what their positions are on tax policy or
health care as much.
Because really, it seems like today in politics,
you can kind of have opinions on those issues
and be on the left or right.
What really matters and what really feels
like a dividing line in politics today is
cultural issues and social issues.
So the reactionaries, that is your focus,
like you said on critical race theory and
school on the current.
Fear about gender being taught in elementary
schools.
Black Lives Matter, all these cultural social
issues that seem to have taken over our politics
today.
I think those are white reactionaries or glomming
on to and are really talking and saying, we
see these changes that are happening and we
want to go back to the world before those
changes were happening now.
Speaker 1: In the article, the reactionary
trap, which we will link to you, also point
out the left is not immune from this, and
also that social media has a role to play
in kind of creating these fear based, reactionary,
almost like feedback loop.
So can you talk about that a little bit?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
So in the article, I talk about a few people
who were on the left and kind of jumped the
shark and became reactionaries like I was
speaking about on these cultural and social
issues.
And the point that I wanted to make is that
I think that people on the left need to be
aware that it's possible for them to become
reactionary, even if they think, Look, I'm
left on health care and left on gun issues.
I'm on the left, so I can't be reactionary.
They need to be aware that because the dividing
line in politics today seems to be these social
issues, if you become a reactionary on somehow
every single one of these social issues, it's
possible that maybe you're no longer a member
of the left, but you've become sort of a reactionary
and that you need to be aware of this, that
maybe you can kind of avoid a politics that
only relies on opposition and is only based
on fear.
And you just start to have a positive vision
for maybe what you want your politics to look
like and you want the country to look like.
And so essentially, the article talked about
a few of these people who are on the left
and sort of sublimated.
They skipped the middle phase and became reactionaries
on the right.
And and I think a big part of what happened
to them is that they got involved on Twitter.
They started to get a feedback loop of people
who were rewarding them for criticizing the
left on social issues.
They both have an audience of those type of
people, and then they were unable to criticize
the left on any issues, and they sort of became
reactionaries out without any, any real thought
about what was happening to them just by following
their instincts and following their social
media following.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I can kind of understand
how it can happen because, you know, over
the last many years, I've waded into topics
like, for example, when the term regressive
left was a big thing.
I was glad to say, Hey, you know what?
There is this thing of people who operate
under the label of being left, but they're
really quite authoritarian.
And that's not a leftism that I recognize,
right?
For example, which to me is relatively uncontroversial.
Like, these things exist in any political
movement.
And there was a reaction, a very loud reaction
from a slice of my audience focused exclusively
on that, which if I had just latched on to
that, it probably would have pulled me into
a completely different audience.
Maybe it would have been lucrative.
Maybe it would have, but would have allowed
growth.
I was only interested in going as far as I
believe the facts suggested on that, but it
seems like you can.
You will very quickly start hearing from a
slice of your audience and they will pull
you towards those views.
Speaker 3: I think that's 100 percent right
and it's oftentimes going to be the loudest
and most active part of your audience.
And so you're going to see all these people
reacting.
The thing that you said that was maybe the
most exciting and you're going to say, Oh,
wow, maybe this is what's getting my audience
excited as you give them more of this content.
It's it's called audience capture.
And I think it's something that the people
who checks on Twitter and a lot of these people
who are maybe more reactionary on their social
views get a lot of a response from those people
on Twitter and they get really pulled into
that world.
And I don't think it's I don't think it's
only something that happened with the right.
I think it can happen on the left, too.
And I think it just happens to be that it's
the most radical sides of either base that
really, really is the most active on Twitter
and on social media.
And it's really pulling people to the most
to the most radical parts of their party or
their social movement.
I think it's honestly particularly noticeable
on the right on Twitter only because it's
it seems like it brings out the most vile
part of people, and it really gets them excited
to see it on Twitter.
When you're just when you're scrolling through
it and it gives you an emotional reaction
and you end and pulls out a side of you that
wants to respond and wants to get engaged.
And I think it's important to take a step
back and say, Well, this isn't how the world
actually is.
This is just a certain portion of Twitter
that's really this reactionary in this grotesque.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And I find that I will often get questions
like as an example there.
I don't know if you remember this, but shortly
after Trump was elected in 2016, we saw the
rise of the Women's March.
And then there was this controversy where
some of the Women's March leaders felt that
Jewish women were sort of like not intersectional
enough or not discriminated against enough.
To qualify for like board or leadership membership,
I called that out wholeheartedly and talked
about, you know, the dismissal of anti-Semitism
and Jewish disgrace, anti-Jewish discrimination.
But I also recognize like this is a pretty
small slice of the left.
It was sort of like an attempt to keep that
proportionality in check, as you mentioned.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think that's really important.
I think there was a study that was done on
the Hidden Tribe study, and it said like seven
percent of of users on Twitter are the most
are progressive activists.
About seven percent are conservative reactionaries
or something equivalent on the right.
Whether they create the vast majority of the
content on Twitter, and I think that's because
one they're probably the most excited about
their political projects, the most active
and two, I think that they make it so that
the rest of the users on Twitter are fearful
of of saying anything or fearful of using
the platform because they might get attacked
by one or either side of those of the political
spectrum, right?
And so I think, you
Speaker 1: know what I was, I was going to
say, what are the if we have an interest in
having some tools with which we can sort of
like pump the brakes when we start getting
sucked into some of these things?
You sort of alluded to some of these things,
which is one is asking how big of a problem
is this really?
What are some of the other questions that
one can kind of ask themselves as they start
getting pulled into some of these reactionary
loops?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think the first and foremost
thing is to make sure that you have principles
and values that you're following, rather than
just reacting and seeing something and saying,
Oh, that scares me or I don't like that, I'm
going to go on the other side of that issue.
I think it's really important for people to
think through what are my values, what is
my political project and what is the positive
vision that I have for the world.
The second is being willing to consider the
possibility that you're wrong.
I think it's really important for people to
understand that they're not always right.
And one of the amazing things about Twitter
is that we can outsource asking questions
we can outsource.
We only have one brain, and when there's millions
of brains on Twitters on Twitter, I think
it's useful to think, OK, maybe I'm wrong.
I need to really consider what other people
are pushing back on me for or the ideas that
they're bringing to the table.
And then the last one, I think, is to avoid
us versus them thinking it's really easy to
fall into the trap where you say, This is
my side, I'm going to agree with everything
on this side and everyone who is on the other
side of this political issue or on the other
side of the political divide has bad motives
or is wrong on every single issue.
And so I think if you do those three things,
one, make sure you have a positive vision
to don't, don't fall into us versus them thinking.
And then three, be able to consider the possibility
that you're wrong, then you'll avoid this,
this reactionary thinking that a lot of people
have fallen into.
Speaker 1: What do you suspect happened with
someone like, for example, Dave Rubin, who
you write about in the article?
You know, I used to be quite friendly with
Dave, and we would text and chat on the phone,
sometimes years and years ago and more recently,
you know, he's attacked me publicly.
He's kind of sent me text privately and like
my view has been, I don't know if he was like
38 or 40 at the time that this political reawakening
kind of happened.
But I've not really met people in my life
whose politics so dramatically changes at
that age unless they were almost like not
even engaged at all.
And they didn't even really have, like a formative
politics.
So it's hard for me to imagine that his views
really changed.
So it's easy to say he was captured by the
audience and he was captured by, you know,
getting to know Trump and this type of thing.
But I just don't really know what to make
of it like.
What's your sense of that particular example?
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's hard to get into into
people's heads, but generally what I think,
I think happens to a lot of these people is
that they go against.
Well, one I think it's important to note that
the mid 2010s, the early 2010s and when Trump
came along, there was a lot of social change
in terms of Black Lives Matter.
And there was a lot of this cultural change
that made people fearful.
So I think that brought out a certain type
of person who maybe was progressive on other
issues, but then they realized that they maybe
they're more reactionary on these more cultural
issues.
The second thing I think that happens a lot
is that maybe someone who is on the left goes
against one of the progressive dogmas or one
of the progressive cataclysms on these progressive
issues.
And then they get really dogpile by people
on the left and they think, Whoa, whoa, what
has happened?
And I thought these were my allies.
I thought these were my friends.
And then they kind of, rather than think,
having a somewhat rational reaction and thinking,
OK, either one.
Maybe I got this issue wrong or two.
Maybe the rest of my team is being a little
bit irrational on this issue.
They kind of jumped to the other team and
then the other team or the other side accepts
them because.
They say, look, now we have someone from the
left on our side.
And I think that it gives them more credibility.
Speaker 1: And in a sense, it does.
I mean, these folks are very useful to the
right, it seems to me.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think it is true because
when people, when people on the right say,
Look, we even have people on the left who
are joining us on this issue, this issue,
this issue.
And they once were really like, the young
Turks are a far progressive left and they
can say, Oh, the left has kind of just gone
crazy on these issues.
And maybe, maybe there is some time for reflection
on both sides like the left could say, really
think through what do we need to be dogpile
and people who go against us on one specific
issue, is it really worth it?
Ostracizing somebody and kicking them out
of our club just because they go against one
of these?
One of our progressive dogmas and the people
who are leading the left need to really reconsider.
Look, are these the people that are really,
truly align with on all my political beliefs?
Or am I making just kind of a rash reaction
to being attacked online?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think both sides are important.
The people doing the leaving should really
consider whether they're aligning with the
right people.
But the people putting in place the litmus
or purity test should also kind of kind of
consider the impact of that.
We've been speaking with Seth Moskowitz, who's
a journalist writing about American politics
and technology.
He's an editor at Persuasion Magazine and
will link to his article, The Reactionary
Trap.
Seth, I really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 3: Thank you very much.
I appreciate being here